well it's very simple what I said was
that there were low interest rates and
lacks regulations the financial sector
mortgage try encouraged people to borrow
and when you're alone there were nine
hundred and fifty billion dollars or
what are called mortgage equity
withdrawals people were taking money out
of their mortgages out of their houses
and spending much of that the
low-interest breaks didn't stimulate a
investment boom factories and things
that would have made our economy more
productive what happened was there was a
little bit of investment but in houses
beyond people's ability to pay
they had innovation but they were
innovations that were in effect intended
to get around the kinds of Prudential
standards that have been the basis of of
the soundness of our system so for
instance they were lending mortgages
that were a hundred percent some cases
more than hundred percent they didn't
even have to pay the interest that was
due they at the end of the year they
they owe more money that they did at the
beginning of the years they said don't
worry because the price of housing was
going to go up and you would be
wealthier well what they were promising
was if what economists would say is a
free lunch but we say there's no such
thing as a free lunch if it were true
that just by buying a house at the end
of the year you would be wealthier
everybody would have done it and it the
system could have worked so what made it
particularly obvious that something was
wrong was that while housing prices were
going up and up the income of Americans
was not going up and up the median ex
the person in the middle income was
going down people at the bottom were
getting worse off so you had an
impossibility you know
need a Nobel Prize to figure out that if
houses are going prophesies are going up
and incomes are going down there's going
to be a problem you can't spend more
than a hundred percent of your income
and housing and it was a gamble but it
was a gamble which we were fairly sure
we knew what the outcome would be and
that was the disaster that we're seeing
now what they did then was to take the
mortgages in the old days a bank would
originate a mortgage and then hold on to
the mortgage it made a bad mortgage it
would bear the consequence but there was
a new innovation called securitization
securitization are not enabled the
diversification of risk around the world
but diversification had another problem
and I sometimes joke the students in my
class after I explained the advantage of
diversification ran down to Wall Street
to make money and didn't listen to the
second half of the lecture the second
half of the lecture was about the
problems of diversification the problems
of diversification it creates a new
information asymmetry the person
originating the mortgage knew more about
the mortgage than the person buying the
market you sold the mortgage to people
all over the world we we did it we based
it on the principle that a fool was born
every minute
and we would find those fools anywhere
in the world globalization open up a new
opportunity to find new people to
exploit their ignorance and we found
them the losses in Europe have been
actually greater than in America in the
subprime mortgage area but this was all
the house of cards so Lehman was one of
the companies that was particularly
exposed to having bought these mortgages
they repackaged these mortgages there
were many other people involved in this
and the scam the rating agencies
believed in financial alchemy you know
in the old days alchemy you took LED and
convert it into gold and can't do that
of course they believed they could take
F rated subprime mortgages borrowings by
people well
beyond their ability to pay and then
engaging some magic a financial alchemy
and convert it into a rated products
that could be held in the portfolio's of
pension funds safe enough to be held by
banks to be holy obey anybody but of
course it wasn't based on reality and
there were some obvious problems that
the rating agencies were being paid by
the people who were engaged in producing
these complicated financial products
that were sewn on trying transparent
that not even those who own them
understood what was going on so the
reason Lehman Brothers went down is two
foes a owned a lot of these bad assets
but also because the products were so
non transparent because they engaged in
so much of this accounting gimmickry
that no one had any confidence the
financial markets are based on trust you
give your money and today and you hope
to get the money back with our interest
but if the people you give your money to
may walk away with your money pay it to
their executives and high bonuses and
what you're left with is a lot of rotten
assets you're not going to have that
same trust and what's happened is has
been the loss of that trust so no one
wants to turn over their money to help
Lehman Brothers because they said we
don't know what your assets are worth